how's it going my bros my name is beard
we're gonna play escape by flames of the
three no description best description
ever so I don't have to read anything
actually I did have to read no
description but I didn't have to read
anything more than two letters and we
jump up here and laying on bed how y'all
doin mr. chairs I lost I lost P did you
find me real quick this time actually so
I'm not gonna complain where you are or
what you did but let's get out of here
okay oh now that'd be like that um I'm
so sick of you hitting me I'm sorry it's
fauna
holy crap yeah like ten seconds after
yes freaking love find my old barge oh
no it's stuck
can we leave though okay so I guess we
woke up and sofa nose I sing you a
lullaby you don't you remember oh man
what up piggy a perm pity I'm pretty
pumped I'm sorry if I scared you I'm
sorry if I scared you but man I'm so
pumped I'm pumped I'm freaking pumped
did you see my stump throw did you see
my friggin pump jump pump jump did you
see that
yeah well I'm man piggy you scared
living penis out of me oh man
flying piggy hates you pinky hey I'm a
man oh don't be like eight I mean I pump
and pump look at me I'm so tough
yes yes yes okay this is freaking I'm
gonna leave you guys to and you guys can
talk to each other well I'll go in here
like for Vic sets on the floor googly
with to the floor
this puzzle probably not whatever I
forgot to log out of steam gonna pretend
that I did you guys look being naked at
the moment I'm so funny
okay okay watch going on into this drum
breakdown so on the flower I mean that's
not far this is they roll but whatever
okay
Pierre Stefano I want to take both but I
know mr. fatter
um don't date me pity I will seriously
kill you do if you threaten me I don't
have to take you in mr. hammer leg I'm a
fracking like okay let's focus let's
focus let's put you down there maybe
there's your key there trouble doing
360s landing on see oh there it is okay
sorry about this Stefano alright I
didn't even have to do it I just
okay let's go okay which way that toy
beating all right
barrels about where right [ __ ] never
right babe barrels can never trust bear
I [ __ ] hate there's so much
oh man a key for me okay let's go
Stefano this way
the barrels watch out for the barrel
spinning no [ __ ] hate barrels hello
hi oh I keep getting teased but I never
have to use them alright be careful
buddy
I have a bad feeling about this room me
to have a better feeling about every
room in this game oh okay
wiser I'll go spare bed here must be
something underneath it
you look good on that bed Stefano why
don't you join me hey I'm just kidding
I'm not gay
what's that huh what oh man right
towards us everywhere
no stay bra stay bro no you're doing it
wrong mr. chest okay like I don't think
there's any one thing in here actually
it's girls - oh okay now here's key
which one though machine room no no one
of them use works really not use the key
oh oh didn't make a noise that's fine
okay man I don't like this idea of this
pity be careful and don't hit me on
something everything
I'm so sick of it I should wear a
friggin helmet I'm sorry it's funny I'm
really okay with like Talia bar okay
that's the Lisa fauna but maybe it's
good so you can show a little
okay cat good I actually miss him mr.
Sher Wow y'all know uh where's chair oh
look at that
so money I thought that I had my own
answer okay buddy you're finally madam
oh don't worry okay
nananananana moe I told you pretty I
told you we're fighting I'm so proud of
you I'm such a meringue okay I just need
it no wait
are you scared pretty you wanted me to
come with you
mr. trash is a statue all right let's do
this together pretty common problem
remember Shamu okay ah dinette I fine it
done just yourself
don't you dare I'm cursed your step
[ __ ] knew it
I don't even need to go here this is
yours put it in your body and you black
know what did you do any my side my
buddy yeah go back you know
trust yourself yeah
I don't jest yeah that's what you get
you shout in PT you shout I know I know
dust it and I don't dress yeah
yep what thanks is going on and I don't
trust ya oh yeah
mm trust okay let's go for a triple kill
double kill
holy [ __ ] that was awesome just yeah
what's going on here I never seen so
many dead bodies in my life did it bro
do it yeah the bro why all right I just
think they had a gangbang to be honest
and they're just sleepy afterwards this
is my way of seeing it let's go to the
third man freaking lovelyz mom so far
mean yes I love pity
I am golden a vision I am the better of
safari let's do this okay I know your
bad sauna you're not the town when a
super difficult puzzles ok pity I know
this is good be at five you shouldn't
thank you I don't think you realize you
mean I told you to be careful
don't what is this it's an eagle I don't
like you use the phone all the followers
really ok oh [ __ ] stop with a friggin
girls girl I would never thought the bro
would do this he's turned into a monster
I have to end this no oculus and is now
savanna man
a piano is creeping the heck out of okay
ah that mailman man that's a pest that
you pity
hello has so many freaking items okay
told ya a million freaking okay that's
what's going on here
doctor [ __ ] happen to his office oh oh
he's like I want hugs oh man it scared
the crap out of me oh you came out of
the closet
freaking naked guys how did it call it
never good news I don't dress like a
murmurs anyone make them fall actually
good I guess
no you saw my keys
I don't trust this room what's going on
here I'm back where I began
but there's oh there's the father what
this is going on it's all red with you
even though you may never have anything
oh no oh man that was gonna be pulled
for oh man that's an even spawn over
there I'll linky let's just go don't
leave it sexy mood sexy word is never
good news unless you're about to have
sex like a script
whatever rape it's not I guess it's a
second color sex but it's not sex
drywall and I'm about hurt me
loud crash whatever that was it was
[ __ ] amazing thank you for making
that mod for me if you want to download
it I'll leave the download link in
description please give it a thumbs up
and add it to your favorites I hope you
enjoyed I really enjoy that that was
hilarious
freakin piggy piggy rape in the
beginning oh man I just love when you do
with this stuff or like for me I mean I
remember I didn't realize that this was
I uh I downloaded them all but I didn't
and he said I made this for you but I
didn't realize I was playing that mod
right now I thought I was doing
something else but so it was cool that I
didn't know about it it made it more fun
but uh yeah that was pretty much it
huh are you [ __ ] gay to me told me
hey [ __ ] job no way no [ __ ] way